veramente un piacere essere qui è un
onore grandissimo e soprattutto perché
anche io sono legato molto alle mie
origini cioè sono molto legato alle mie
origini
pensando a questa parola sono venuto in
mente altre tre parole che sono musica e
fede motivo
inizio con la prima parola
che musica
voi tutti non sapete magari qualcuno di
voi mi conosce qualcun altro no ma una
cosa che molti non sanno è che la mia
musica origine grazie alla chiesa
grazie alla fede diciamo insieme a mio
padre quando ero piccolo circa avevamo
avevo dieci anni mi sono avvicinato al
mondo della musica appunto grazie a lui
e grazie alla chiesa lui e adesso un
pastore insieme a mia madre di una
chiesa evangelica una chiesa che al
tempo diciamo che stava nascendo
io vedevo lui che portava tutti questi
strumenti strani a casa al tempo ero
piccolo ed era anche un attimo proibito
toccarli perché vivevamo il tempo in un
condominio e una batteria in un
condominio fa parecchio rumore e avevo
questa cosa che mi
mi dava qualcosa quando la vedevo quando
sentivo gli strumenti quando suonavo
strumenti sentivo che stavo bene non
pensavo a tutto il resto la testa che
viaggia parecchio ma quando facevo
quella cosa mi rendevo conto che tutto
quanto tutto quello che avevo in mente
all'improvviso spariva e ho coltivato
questa mia passione
anche crescendo verso di poi 12 13 14
anni mi sono appassionato il mondo del
rap in particolare al freestyle che è
una pratica diciamo che si fa tra rapper
dove si improvvisano delle rime al
momento su una base che ne so magari con
un argomento oppure semplicemente a
prendersi in giro io ero uno di quelli
che si prendeva in giro parecchio con i
suoi amici
crescendo questa
questa cosa l'ho sfogata lo sfocato
sempre di più perché mi piaceva stare
bene fino a quando non ho scritto il mio
la mia prima canzone
adesso ve ne faccio sentire una piccola
parte è veramente è un pezzo del
2016 veramente piccolissimo e per la
prima volta avevo scoperto e ho scoperto
che potevo per registrare la mia musica
potevo oltre che fare freestyle e
prendermi in giro con i miei amici anche
portare questa mia origine e questo
amore che portava verso la musica verso
un qualcos'altro che al tempo
un dato che ero giovane arrabbiato non
capivo il mio scopo nella vita era erano
parole che adesso sentirete un po non
tanto piacevoli però poi è andata avanti
la situazione vi faccio sentire giusto
30 secondi
a volte mi capita di sentirmi inferiore
si pone tematica giudici sono deluso
generali city rapida sanitaria che
scarica mio gatto
[Musica]
ultimamente è diventato un pizzo di
costi gabbia vinco anche la notte del
giudizio il nostro capo così sangue
dello sconfitto dopo l'ennesimo bastardo
ok
a risentire questa roba dopo tanto tempo
vi dico la verità un po me ne vergogno
perché effettivamente non dava un bel
messaggio però ho avuto sempre almeno
quella coerenza di dire né me né i miei
pezzi e nelle mie canzoni voglio
raccontare sempre e solamente la verità
quello che vivo non voglio inventarmi
cose perché non mi farebbe stare bene lo
faccio per questo
con il passare del tempo io cresco e la
mia origine si evolve grazie all'amore
io provo l'amore per la prima volta
provo una grande delusione in amore per
la prima volta dove
in poche parole vengo tradito entra nel
mondo dei grandi anche se
ero piccolo sia da una ragazza che amavo
molto e anche da qualche amico
la mia origine evolve in questo grazie a
questo avvenimento io inizio a scrivere
in maniera diversa a fare musica maniera
diversa a raccontare cose diverse dato
che stavo vivendo cose diverse
finché non arrivò a proprio cambiare del
tutto la mia musica questa che gli farò
sentire a un altro spezzone di 30
secondi del primo pezzo in assoluto
d'amore che ho fatto poi spiegano un
attimo la sua storia
quella volta
[Musica]
la forza di restare ancora
non ce l'hanno thomas e rose più come mi
basta
come potete notare formenti una cosa
diversa cioè si sente secondo me avverto
io con il passare del tempo poi se
sbaglio correggetemi si sente un po la
sofferenza quella
quella cosa che avevo provato il fatto
che la mia musica è il mostro che io ho
sempre portato dentro che quello
dell'arte della musica in qualche modo
grazie a quella situazione si stava
stava evolvendo
andando avanti con il tempo ho fatto un
altro paio di brani dopo questo al tempo
eravamo l'unico gruppo di riccione io
vengo da riccione che
portava musica che aveva il coraggio di
portare musica che riusciva a fare
qualche qualche ascolto che la musica
dopo questa canzone ce ne furono un
altro paio
e continuavo a capire sempre di più che
questa cosa mi faceva stare bene che la
sentivo mia finché scrivendo e
continuando a scrivere non è arrivata
un'altra mia origine che penso sia
l'origine del mio successo che è chiasso
è la canzone che una canzone che oggi
conta 3 4 dischi di platino se non
sbaglio
e ha un'origine veramente fantastica
nasce è l'origine del mio successo e la
sua origine è ancora più soddisfacente
nel senso che era un momento un attimo
buio della mia vita avevo appena
lasciato la scuola perché non riuscivo
anche se la scuola importantissima
fondamentale l'istruzione tutto il resto
io personalmente non riuscivo a sentirmi
a mio agio tra quei banchi e mi sentivo
sono uno che ha bisogno di parlare di
muoversi di fare
ho lasciato la scuola subito ho
preferito andare a lavorare questo pezzo
chiasso nasce proprio sul cantiere su
quel cantiere tra il sudore e la voglia
di arrivare che comunque era sempre
lontana perché da riccione che una
realtà un attimo distante dal mondo
della musica importante che questo pezzo
lo scrissi proprio un giorno in cui per
la prima volta stava montando le
mattonelle
nell'azienda di mio padre e mio padre
non voleva assolutamente che io facessi
le cose da solo ma avevo questo
ritornello nella testa e piano piano
praticamente da che dovevo farmi una
piccola parte di matto della casa me la
sono fatta tutta cantando e continuando
a scrivere in questo ritornello il
problema è che quando arrivato
praticamente le mattonelle erano tutte
una sopra l'altra quindi mi ha sgridato
malamente anche se questo mio successo
di chiasso è arrivato veloce quindi
anche se questo successo alla mia
origine perché uno dei miei primi pezzi
d'amore non vuol dire che è successo sia
dietro la porta
infatti come di stato spiegando questo
per azionato dal cantiere è veramente
altre cose ma prima di riuscire ad
uscire ad arrivare al grande pubblico ci
sono stati veramente tante difficoltà
tanti imprevisti abbiamo fatto versioni
su versioni poi una volta il manager non
piaceva poi quando faceva il manager del
produttore non era convinto e abbiamo
finito praticamente che due giorni prima
dell'uscita abbiamo deciso di rifare
completamente tutta la canzone per vari
di nappi varie dinamiche e questa
costanza questo amore questo desiderio
questo amare e portare alta questa
origine ci ha portato oggi ad avere
fatto veramente una grande hit e oggi mi
ritrovo mi ritrovo onorato anche a
parlare in mezzo a voi è vero che arrivò
dalla chiesa però per il grande pubblico
io arrivo da chiasso quindi avevo
bisogno di spiegarvi questa cosa
grazie a questa cosa mi collego anche
alla seconda parola che è la fede come
vi ho detto prima ho iniziato a suonare
in chiesa e la fede per me è una cosa
che
indispensabile perché mi
mi collega e mi tiene collegato sempre
con la mia famiglia con la mia terra io
sono di origini napoletane quindi ho un
grande legame con con la mia terra con
la mia famiglia
l'unica cosa è che bisogna sempre tener
la focalizzata perché da quando sono
diventato random e da quando ho iniziato
ad avere un po di successo
per un attimo stando lontano tra viaggi
mille lavori per un attimo ho
dimenticato alle mie origini e quando
dimentichi le tue origini secondo me è
dimentichi chi sei anche tutto quello
che sai quando perdi i tuoi ricordi il
tuo vissuto
rimane nullo e l'unico modo per
ritrovarli appunto è stato ritornare a
casa per ritornare dalla mia mamma dalla
mia famiglia delle belle cose che mi
fanno stare bene le cose semplici della
vita che amo tanto
questa fede
mi porta mi porta a prendere delle
scelte giuste mi tiene lontano da delle
cose sbagliate che la vita ad offrirmi
mi aiuta a perdonare il prossimo
mi aiuta a vedere sempre il bicchiere
mezzo pieno
penso che senza senza questi valori
senza questa questo amore per la mia
origine oggi non sarei qui un'altra cosa
che la fede magari può fare per me e che
ha fatto per me in passato è stato
aiutarmi a trovare il motivo della mia
esistenza che appunto la terza parola il
motivo il motivo della mia esistenza io
voglio che
la gente capisca cerco di trasmetterlo
anche tramite la mia musica che nessuno
è inutile e nessuno ha origine senza
motivo tutti quanti noi siamo nati per
uno scopo per fare qualcosa ognuno di
noi è una capacità un qualcosa che sa
fare
o semplicemente un qualcosa che lo fa
stare bene secondo me poi sono piccolo
21 anni non so ancora quale lo scopo
della vita ma da quello che ho capito
fino adesso il mio scopo nella vita è la
cosa che ha svoltato la mia vita è stata
trovare il motivo della mia vita e penso
che sia lo scopo trovare il motivo della
nostra esistenza dentro di noi ma senza
vergognarsi di quello che magari può
essere un osso istinto perché magari a
14 13 anni quando avevo questa cosa
della musica che era un istinto che mi
ha portato a farla naturalmente se mi
fossi vergognato di quelli senso magari
oggi non fare il cantante non avrei
trovato e realizzato mio sogno
quindi voglio che sia chiara questa cosa
per noi molto importante che tutti lo
sappiano e soprattutto una volta trovato
questo motivo una volta iniziata la vita
una volta
che siamo lì è fondamentale portarle
sempre dietro alle proprie origini
io l'ho fatto per un periodo l'ho persa
oggi sono fiero di avervi ritrovate
voglio mandarvi un messaggio di
incoraggiamento per non perderle mai
perché senza le nostre origini alla fine
non siamo noi stessi
grazie a tutti